do you suffer from depression at all i
was thinking about this last night yeah
do you
yeah i knew it yeah which is weird
because i've never seen it out of you
no but first well every last time like i
bet josh suffers from different yeah
yeah i go i have i have um i have some
dark
spells i really do have some dark spells
and uh how dark we talking have you and
were you always like this
because depression's like because cats
i'm not saying anything
that cat hasn't said on air i'm not
earning her laundry but cat suffers from
depression too
but i can tell right when cat when cat
yeah you have a really you walk in i'm
like
cat yeah cat as uh dove davidoff would
say has a touch of the dog
yeah i mean my dad used to say that guy
has a touch of the downs
oh yeah he'd be like that guy looks like
he was just good god gave him just a
touch the hilarious yeah
if you have depression your dad's saying
no no no no just in general
that's funny um but not like he was not
like full but like god was like here
you're just a little just a touch
yeah i feel you i i would tell you in
public
the days you see me the happiest i'm
overcompensating
i'm overcompensating and have you always
been you've always struggled with
depression i don't know how to answer
that because i think when i was younger
i'm not sure i knew
i would have i would identify like would
you wake up sad though when you're
younger
um yeah some
it's been because they they say it is
like uh
it's a genetic right yeah so there's a
good chance your kids are probably gonna
suffer from it
so i think for sure that um
jacob has a little bit of it i i mean my
daughter has her
already had we have has her issues for
me
uh my oldest son i don't know i i don't
think he does he's going through some
tough times but i don't know if he
technically has a military kid
yeah but but for me man on medication
am i no i
my depression is always about it always
comes down to and i don't know about you
cat
but it it's such self-loathing
and it's got nothing to do with anything
around me it's never depressed about my
career it's never depressed about my
family
it's i hit a period of a couple days
where i just think i'm the biggest piece
of [ __ ]
and i just same with you cat yeah it's
really hard
for me ain't nothing you can do huh i
can't shake it at him i can't
shake it out of my own the only thing
that keeps me
sane is i'm old enough
and i've been through it enough to know
you'll get through it this is going to
end
this is not what i know when you're when
you have the touch of the dog
uh beth does my wife does she knows what
they do
growing up do the kids notice no because
you know
um like i said i'm pretty good
of over compensating but the more i
overcompensate the worse i feel about
myself
that makes sense so the happier i
pretend to be the more
the deeper the fall do you have
depression chin
no i suffered from anxiety for like a
few years but then
i kind of went away you have anxiety but
do you do you get attacks
uh define attack your heart races you
sweat
uh you feel like you're gonna have a
heart attack none of that have attacked
it's just like a kind of a cut if it
scale one to ten would be a
four throughout the week oh that's not
terrible four or five
i mean you just you're like oh come on
dude but does it does it does it
interfere with your
day-to-day like does it does no power no
you know i might lose sleep or i might
be not present at home when it happens
why did you think that i have no idea
yeah i knew it though
i don't know i was like i bet because i
have so many friends that suffer from it
like
i bet josh has depression well one of
the things and one of the reasons why i
really
focus on being positive and
and um and lifting myself and other
people up and not focusing on negative
and is because if if i sink it it's easy
for me to sink into it
like for me to remember to stay positive
does it happen once a month for you
honestly when i can when i can mentally
keep up with myself and try to remind
myself about things that i do have and
things not things that i don't have
things that i can do and not things that
i can't do
i can really help myself but at least
i would say once every six weeks or so
it just hits
hard it's a gut punch do you miss shows
no i've never missed anything
i've never missed anything i've had
crying fits in the green room because i
would get off stage and just be like you
suck
i always have to clean it clear it out
but but i
i and i don't feel like you haven't had
a spell in a wildcat
do you take medication i do not take
medication i don't know it i've been
depressed since i met you though
like i've been depressed for the last
like two years to a certain level though
yeah to a certain level it's always
pretty manageable and then every couple
of months i'll get it it'll get bad
it'll get really good and how many days
it lasts for you
uh usually a couple weeks see mine
doesn't don't last that long and is it
for you
is it self-loathing is it or is it more
about
i don't know everything just feels
really great it's like i don't feel
anything it's
weird it's almost like uh everything's
heavy yeah everything's heavy
everything's like very
gray i have like no motivation to do
anything
to do something you don't want to talk
about anybody i don't know how to
explain this but things almost
sound different it's sound everything
sounds so
monotone and just medication can help
with that
cat you don't want to try it out no why
not try it out though i don't i don't
like the idea of taking me either
medicine for if i don't need to me too
in my head like if i've already gotten
to this point in my life
without medication i know well enough
that there are certain things i can do
to help it it may never
like take care of the issue but i don't
want to but what if and i don't know
i have no i'm talking about my ass here
but i know people that suffer from it
who are very close to me and they're on
medication it really helps
it helps a lot of people but does it i
think my
my thing is that like i've heard some
people say it just dulls me out
yep i've heard that and so i've heard
some people were like oh i wouldn't be
on this earth if i didn't have it
and it's great and i've heard from other
people especially creatives like oh it
makes me
that's the creative i don't mind hitting
that
hole for three or four days every six
weeks or so
i'm just scared that it could that it
will just dull me out
what if it makes you guys awesome i mean
if you've been dealing with since i've
known you
you know what i'm saying and then it's
really really bad for weeks mm-hmm
it's been like that since i was like a
kid though weird
yeah your parents were never like
emotional
no they i don't think they really even
allowed to see other people
they didn't know it was like an issue
until i was like 18.
genetically it's something with a
chemical imbalance for you yeah like my
sister has something
my sister has it too my sister's bipolar
can you feel it coming on when it
happens
yeah i can kind of feel it trickling in
yeah and and do you almost prepare
yourself mentally
yeah i kind of give people a heads up
like hey if i disappear for a couple
weeks
like you don't hear from me i'm fine i
tell you don't like check into the
podcast and make sure that
i'm at work and i'm like if i'm at work
i'm good does it does it
affect you going places do you miss work
do you miss work but she's not she
i can't when it's a bad freak catch
she's not
she's not cat you know you're just like
ah [ __ ] yeah
it's so impossible to explain to people
because you're an intelligent person i'm
half intelligent i know when i'm in it
i know when i'm in it and i'm like i'm
in it just get yourself
out of it and it just doesn't happen one
of my closest friends my brother theo
vaughn
i'm not saying yeah that's not out there
he suffers from it yeah
and dude you're talking jekyll and
[ __ ] hyde man
where i'm learning to deal with it more
now but
it was i mean he'll get dark and
this is the worst and this i'm like what
the [ __ ] and then you realize oh that's
not real and what he's saying he doesn't
mean it's not real
you know or sometimes you know in the
morning he might be as worse so mean him
theo and i don't talk before 11 a.m we
don't because we'd
always fight yeah he'd be like oh dude
and then
at one he would call and apologize i'm
like dude let's just not talk in the
mornings
like let's just skip that don't call me
about any business or anything regarding
the show
we'll just talk later in the afternoon
you're much better he's like i agree
and then but when theo is happy he's the
best [ __ ] person
on the planet [ __ ] yeah he's one of my
favorite people on this earth
when he's sad i know and i forced him to
come to my house
i go t i go theo i i guarantee you
cannot be sat around tiger
guarantee it dude just come over see
what happens and you're not
he won't do it and he'll come over no he
can't he don't have time to think about
his shitty situation whatever he's going
through because tiger is forced to play
hide and go seek
or shoot [ __ ] nerf guns or drag him
to the pool or basketball
and he'll be like do this really help
like a tony dude i think
i didn't notice it as much when my kids
were younger and maybe also because
it was all depression when i was when i
was living in that one
room with them it all kind of sucked
yeah it'd be tough so
i i don't know and maybe just everything
was happening all at once
but the more time alone i've had as
they've gotten older
is the more i've really noticed it i
think social media if you do suffer from
that amplifies everything too i agree
with you there's not a lot of positivity
going on there
we can find it but for in general if
you're going through calm and stuff like
that like
no no successful person is leaving
comics comments so you're
you're getting comments from people who
are not happy
yeah and they're suffering from whatever
you're suffering for and they lash out
on there and you're reading those
comments
and you're downloading that into your
database it's not good man well also
for those of us in this business and
anything really
when you look at social media you think
you're looking at people's actual lives
no they're just showing you the parts
that they want you to see so
no matter when you're scrolling through
all you're looking
at is people who you perceive to have a
better life than you
yes and it's not real no it's everyone's
struggling super depressing
you know everyone has the same problems
too dude yeah whether it's a person
taking a picture in a giant mansion they
still have problems trust me or
blizzarians got their problems
who i heard blizzarians got some dan i
heard
i heard he had some i somebody told me
that
they were coming after him for tax stuff
i could have told you he has problems
from his [ __ ] instagram
you do you don't post pictures with dime
pieces and guns and tanks and you want
your money like that not have
serious issues yeah serious ego
issues self-doubt jacob's worked a
couple problems he has a little dick
you know like and i like him you don't
post that stuff because you're you're
you're throwing this out there for
not just for followers you're doing
something with this dude yeah man you
know
i i've never been to one of those
parties jacob's been to a couple where
he worked a couple and he said it's like
you know those parties you see in the
movies that you don't think actually
happen
he was like that's what his parties are
like and i said how and he said but
um he was like there's just so but i
didn't know this until i looked
i think that he they pay for a lot of
those
women to be there i think 100 percent i
had no idea
oh yeah so the the that party alone must
cost
a gazillion casa gazillion also no one
knows each other you're been to a party
right yo how do you know me i don't
like well that's weird you go over here
how do you know oh we don't
he just invited me it's like an old
brian callum party
i'd go up i'm like oh how do you guys
know each other we don't
okay how do you guys venture we don't
nobody knows you talking about
everything do you know whose house this
is like
no brian just invited random people
and there's no chemistry there's no
there's no vibe in the party like what
the [ __ ] is a bunch of rejects
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song